what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
really really exciting news for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it looks like
a Silver Surfer project is in the works
for Marvel Studios and it could be
coming a lot sooner than you think in
fact it could be coming before the
actual Fantastic Four movie today we
have some details about what type of
project this is going to be for the
Silver Surfer and what exactly is going
to happen in the project we're talking
villains we're talking about where the
project takes place inside of the MCU
and of course we have to talk about what
it means for the Fantastic Four what it
means going forward for Secret Wars and
the big bad villain is Galactus going to
be the villain for the Silver Surfer
project and does that mean if he is
Galactus is going to be a big bad of
Phase 5 or phase six we'll break down
what you need to know about this new
report in this video and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
Marvel and MCU news so first things
first it looks like the Silver Surfer
project is actually going to be a
special presentation on Disney plus
we've talked about this a lot on the
channel but in case you've missed it
recently it has been reported by The
Cosmic circus that Marvel Studios is
planning on doing more special
presentations in the MCU to introduce
new characters werewolf by night that
recently came out on Disney plus was a
special presentation and I personally
think that this is actually a good idea
if done right of course but I believe
that werewolf by night was done right
and I really really enjoyed it it's a
perfect opportunity to introduce a new
character to the MCU have a really
really cool story and set him up to be
used in other projects this really just
helps characters get into the MCU and
the Silver Surfer is a good example we
want the Silver Surfer in the MCU so he
could possibly appear in the Fantastic
Four so he could appear in Avengers
Secret Wars but Marvel Studios might not
have enough time or have a place in the
MCU timeline for a full movie about the
Silver Surfer they might not have the
ability to get a bunch of different
characters to get a bunch of different
actors to get the set made for a full
movie or an entire Disney plus series
however they can do a one hour special
that simply puts the Silver Surfer in
the MCU to where they can use him in
other projects and that is currently
being planned according to this new
report but yes this project will have a
villain and right now it's rumored to be
Galactus let's go over this report and
it's coming from thecosmiccircus.com on
their website the cosmic circus reports
despite all of these rumors and
speculation about the cosmic entities
appearing in the MCU details regarding
the coming of galactus's Herald have
been scarce until now we at the cosmic
circus can confirm that Marvel Studios
is indeed developing a Silver Surfer
solo project they go on to say
additionally our sources confirm giant
freaking robots claim earlier this month
that Marvel has plans for a Silver
Surfer special presentation on Disney
plus so Marvel Studios is developing a
Silver Surfer project and it is going to
be a special presentation on Disney plus
I think that this is a really good idea
as I mentioned before it's kind of a
perfect way to introduce him to the MCU
but Marvel Studios has another plan I
can personally see what Marvel Studios
is doing with these Special
presentations they are opening new sides
to the MCU this is what Marvel did with
werewolf by night they introduced a new
character well they actually introduced
a lot of new characters but they also
introduced the supernatural side of the
MCU so they're preparing people for a
new side of the MCU that's about to be
here shortly we have blade coming up we
have Agatha coven of chaos and there's
even a report that Mephisto has finally
been cast for the MCU appearing for the
first time in the ironheart series so
werewolf by Knight prepped us for the
supernatural side and now it looks like
the Silver Surfer is going to prep us
even more for the cosmic side yes we've
had the cosmic side in the MCU for a bit
but now it looks like we are actually
going to be dealing with the cosmic
entities and that's what Silver Surfer
is going to prepare people for to see in
the MCU because this report goes on to
talk about what we can expect as far as
what the plot is going to be like for
the Silver Surfer project on their
website they say per our sources the
Silver Surfer special presentation will
have a similar style to werewolf By
Night the project will feature norn rad
as galactus's Herald out in the Far
Corners of the cosmos rad will not be on
earth during his special presentation
and will also not interact with any
Cosmic characters already established in
the MCU there are a bit more details
posted in this article about the actual
release date for the Silver Surfer
project but first let's talk about how
it verifies that in this project the
Silver Surfer will indeed be the herald
of Galactus and this is big it's
extremely big I'm not sure how big of a
role Galactus is going to have in this
but considering that he's going to be
his Herald he's going to have somewhat
of a role in it which means this project
is going to introduce Galactus into the
MCU now the report says the Silver
Surfer won't interact with any Cosmic
beings that are already in the MCU like
eternity however Galactus has not yet
been introduced however with the
Fantastic Four movie coming it is
interesting that they want to put the
Silver Surfer and Galactus in the MCU
before then that's right this current
report states that the Silver Surfer
special presentation is going to be
coming out before the Fantastic Four
movie this is what the report says about
the release date it says additionally
our sources confirmed a potential
release window for the upcoming Silver
Surfer special for our sources we're
told that this special presentation will
release a few months before the
Fantastic Four Premiere in February
2025. they continue to say and this is
really big although the current phases
of projects are still on unpredictable
and could shift as time passes we're
being told that the special must release
before the film and this is very
interesting since it must release before
the Fantastic Four film that clearly
means that there are going to be some
things in the Fantastic Four that
happened that you aren't really going to
know about unless you see that Silver
Surfer presentation could the first
villain of the Fantastic Four in the MCU
be the Silver Surfer could it be
Galactus it is quite possible at this
point since you have to watch the
presentation before watching the actual
movie however if I had to guess I'm
assuming Galactus isn't going to be the
main villain of the Fantastic Four film
I'm assuming Marvel Studios is saving
Galactus as a big bad not just for one
movie but over a phase or over a saga in
fact considering galactus's history with
a Multiverse and coming into a new
universe Galactus might even be good at
first he could actually warn the heroes
on Earth what happens when a Multiverse
essentially gets destroyed since he
existed in the previous Universe before
we got our main one now now the Silver
Surfer is a classic Fantastic Four
character and of course we know the
Silver Surfer as a hero he starts off as
a Herald of Galactus but of course has
teamed up with a Fantastic Four to
defeat Galactus but I don't think this
is the story that we're going to see
this story is pretty classic and most
comic book fans know the story plus not
to mention they already did the story on
film in the Fantastic Four the Rise of
the Silver Surfer even though the
depiction of Galactus in that movie was
not very good okay fine it was terrible
but point being this story has been done
before and it's not like Kevin feige to
do something that's already been done to
repeat the same story take a look at
Spider-Man homecoming they didn't do the
original origin of Spider-Man where he
gets bit by the spider why because
that's been told a bunch before Kevin
foggy stated that and with the Silver
Surfer solo presentation they can get
all of that origin out of the way before
introducing him again in the Fantastic
Four that way we don't have to actually
go through the Silver Surfer origin of
him being the herald of Galactus so in
the Fantastic Four movie The Silver
Surfer could very well be introduced in
that film as a good character one who
might have already gotten away from
being the herald of Galactus because I
do think that Galactus is going to be a
big bad probably in Phase seven eight
nine whatever the new saga is after the
Multiverse Saga we already have Kang as
a big bad I do believe that Doom is
coming as well it's just too much to
throw Galactus in right now they don't
want to throw all their cards on the
table and they want to save a really big
villain for the next phase after the
Multiverse Saga so if I had to guess
that's what I'm guessing is going to
happen we might see Galactus before the
end of the Multiverse Saga but I think
he's the big bad after but I do like the
idea of these special presentations that
way they can throw these characters into
other projects the Silver Surfer special
presentation will introduce us to the
character to the people who don't really
know anything about him and then in the
Fantastic Four movie he can appear and
everybody will already know who he is I
personally think it's a good idea but
hey let me know what you think about all
of this in the comments down below
what's your opinion don't forget to like
the video and of course subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos for live updates you can follow
me on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf